when I first heard the title of this
film I thought it was a documentary on
The Wallflowers the rock group it's not
The Perks of Being a Wallflower is based
on a very successful novel which I have
not read I know I haven't read the book
I apologize I have to view this strictly
as a film not let the book get into my
mind I'm reviewing the film here it's
about a young kid in school logan lerman
plays him he's very obscure he has no
friends he had not the greatest
childhood and he runs into this group of
kids Emma Watson and Ezra Miller and get
a lot of adolescent discovery and
basically a coming-of-age tale for
someone very young and learning what
it's like to have friends and live in
school and in this world in general and
just experiencing all that for the first
time really it's times this movie
reminded me of a John Hughes film it
really captures that childlike innocence
you know you had that part of you that
hasn't discovered things yet and it
really is captured beautifully in this
movie I was really impressed with this
movie and it really affected me
emotionally actually because I wasn't
popular when I was in school no one
respected me no one ever picked a fight
with me though because I was always
really tall I never really got that
popular vibe and you know what to be
honest I'm really glad I didn't because
I'd probably be a douchebag logan lerman
has come a long way since percy jackson
he was very good in this movie and emma
watson was good as well Ezra Miller was
definitely a standout his performance
you know it's interesting to see this
after you've seen We Need to Talk About
Kevin and see how evil and just maniacal
he was in that movie and now we have him
here and he's just so he loves life and
he's happy and he's making jokes and
stuff and it really gives you a good
well-rounded view of how good of an
actor that guy actually is the movie
captures a lot of really beautiful
cinematography to these kids like to go
out at night and they like to stand up
in cars and go through tunnels and look
at cityscapes and everything but the
dialogue was so fresh and funny and
different and so strange at times that
you're like why is this working but it
is the movie was just very pure and
that's the best way I can think to
describe this movie is it's a very pure
film it just feels like yes this is
definitely something that I can see
happening to any kid the movie is very
clever also there are secrets and twists
throughout this movie that are very well
hidden and that you don't expect and
they truly are surprising and it really
really caused for much more of an
emotional
resonant feeling because I almost cried
that's impressive because that doesn't
happen me too much the heart and chord
this movie is logan lerman relationship
with emma watson he feels for her he's
really starting to care for her and he
feels like she deserves more love than
what she is being given and paul rudd
plays a teacher in the movie and he says
this great quote he's like we accept the
love we think we deserve and that's
actually true because in real life you
see so many people in relationships and
you're like why are they together what
why are you two together you should be
apart and know when they get in a
relationship it's like they just accept
it so okay I'm finally in a relationship
I don't to worry about being single
anymore and I'm just gonna accept
whatever I get but so many people forget
that they deserve so much more in life
and that's one of the main themes of
this movie and it was beautifully told
and I was really impressed with it the
only issues I had with the film are some
of the ways the film concluded felt a
little sloppy I felt a little
heavy-handed a lot of narration used to
explain things that happens throughout
the movie though it's not a huge problem
the movie looks great it's acted well
the dialogue is very fresh it's touching
it has a great sense of innocence and
childhood pureness in it I'm gonna give
perks of being a wallflower and a - I
really think it's great I've seen a lot
of really good movies lately and I'm
really happy about that some great stuff
has been coming out at the end of this
year thanks a lot for watching guys and
as always if you like this then you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you